we've been following the investigation
that the fbi
and local law enforcement and other
agencies have been doing into the
riotous insurrectionists from january
6th
and over the weekend and over the last
couple of days more and more people have
been getting arrested and booked and
we've seen the mug shots and we've seen
all of it but one of the questions has
been are they going to throw the book at
these folks what are the charges going
to be
is jail time prison time likely and we
got a little bit of insight into that
yesterday at a joint press conference
involving the justice department and the
fbi
where the latest data is that 170 cases
have been opened
um and many folks are going to be facing
some pretty serious charges of the 170
people found so far
70 have been charged and that's expected
to grow
into the hundreds notably there are many
who will be facing charges of sedition
which carries up to 20 years in prison
here is video from the press conference
take a listen
we're looking at significant felony
cases tied to
sedition and conspiracy just yesterday
our office
organized a strike force of very senior
national security prosecutors
and public corruption prosecutors their
only marching orders from me are to
build
seditious and conspiracy charges related
to the most heinous
acts that occurred in the capital and
these are significant charges that have
felonies with uh prison terms of 20 up
to 20 years
in addition to that we're looking in
taking a priority with
cases in which weapons were involved and
cases in which destructive devices were
involved as
people know through news reports there
were pipe bombs found outside the
capitol the atf is working on that metro
police is working on that
fbi's working on that to find that
individual or individuals
who planted those devices so
in addition to just those road cases
we're looking at we're going to focus on
the most significant charges as a
deterrent because
regardless of if it was just a trespass
in the capital
or if someone planted a pipe bomb you
will be charged and you will be found
so there's much to discuss here first of
all
just because they are seeking certain
charges or even
filing certain charges initially tells
us
very little about how much prison time
if any these individuals are going to do
and we're going to talk through that
now in the background of all of this is
another issue
which is that the question of
murder charges also needs to be
considered for those involved in the
deaths that took place
but we'll get to that sort of when when
we come to it i do think it's important
that we temper our expectations and i'll
give you an example of that and i got a
few emails from lawyers about this
my instinct was this and then a few
lawyers in the audience
emailed me about it sedition is a very
high bar
to meet in a court of law
and arguably for good reason because
it's an extremely serious charge
it's essentially a crime against your
country in a way um
and so i doubt we will see many sedition
convictions if any
the legal definition of sedition is is
precise and we'll look at it
but my expectation is we're going to see
people go down for lesser charges
likely still federal charges many
with some prison time associated as well
but
sedition is the act of inciting revolt
or violence against the lawful authority
with the this is the key part with the
goal of destroying or overthrowing it
this is very much like perjury and we've
talked before
about how colloquially speaking perjury
takes place all the time during trials
people get up there and they say things
that aren't true
and and to some degree they know that
they're not true
but proving perjury because you need to
prove intent to deceive
is difficult and it doesn't happen very
often many
i don't know about most it's very common
that in a murder case
you have witnesses who say opposite
things and to some degree they know that
they they are unlikely to be telling
what they know to be the full truth
but you don't see perjury charges you
you don't because it's very difficult to
prove
and a lot of work for prosecutors much
much like with sedition because the goal
of destroying or overthrowing
the authority is part of the definition
of sedition
a good lawyer and some of these people
are going to have good lawyers
many will not but some will a good
lawyer is going to be able to
defeat or at least introduce significant
doubt
about the intent of the actions
they will say maybe listen
they're on camera breaking the window or
doing this or doing this in nancy
pelosi's office or whatever the thing is
um but disturbing the peace
trespassing whatever but to show
intent to overthrow is gonna be really
tough now some of these people were dumb
enough to post their intentions on
social media and in those cases it will
be more difficult
to overcome but uh the point is uh you
know law is weird in that way
and there are good reasons for it in
many cases
um but i think we should just be be
realistic about
uh what what our expectations should be
um
the other the other thing that sometimes
will happen
is that events where things are done as
a group
um you might much more easily be
able to say as a group this was
seditious
as a group what this was was the
attempted overthrow of an authority
but that doesn't necessarily mean you
can apply that exact same intent and
agency to the individual
person in a court of law and to be clear
i'm talking only what we are expecting
to happen
in a court of law so the point is let's
wait and see
but the good news so far is that the
number of people
uh charged is soon to get into the
hundred over 100 and it really should go
significantly higher